DEFEAT.
YOU LATER DECIDE.
FIVE WEEKS FROM TONIGHT.
TRAINING IS NOW LINDSEY GRAHAM.
YOU'VE BEEN GIVING US UPDATES
EVERY STEP OF THE WAY, WHAT'S
THE LATEST?
>> THE KAVANAUGH BUMP IS REAL.
THE BIGGEST CHANGE IN THE 2018
MIDTERMS.
IN NORTH DAKOTA HE SHOULD BE
CONFIRMED.
EVERY -- THERE'S BEEN ASSERTED
BY REPUBLICANS, WHY?
WHETHER YOU ARE A TRUMP
REPUBLICAN, LIBERTARIAN,
VEGETARIAN, McCAIN REPUBLICAN,
ROMNEY REPUBLICAN, BUSH
REPUBLICAN, YOU ARE MAD AS HELL
BECAUSE WE ARE ALL UNITED THAT
THIS IS UNFAIR WHAT THEY ARE
DOING TO THIS GOOD DECENT MAN.
THE REPUBLICANS HE WILL BE A
DEMOCRAT, NOT A REPUBLICAN.
YOU'VE BEEN ABLE TO DO SOMETHING
THAT I COULD NEVER DO, UNITE
THIS PARTY.
>> Sean: THE ANGER IS REAL.
>> WHAT TO DO WHAT YOU HAVE TO
SWAY GOOD MEN AND THE ONLY WAY
HE STAYS
DESTROYED IS IF WE BUY INTO
THIS TRAP.
PUTTING HIM ON THE COURT IS THE
ONLY ANTIDOTE.
>> Sean: YOU WERE A
PROSECUTOR.
WHEN YOU SEE NO CORROBORATION --
>> I DON'T PROSECUTE.
>> Sean: YOU DON'T PROSECUTE.
>> THE LAW REQUIRES YOU TO TELL
THE ACCUSED WHERE IT HAPPENED,
WHEN IT HAPPENED AND TO HAVE
CORROBORATION THAT IT DID
HAPPEN.
MY BEEF IS NOT WITH DR. FORD.
I THINK SHE'S BEEN USED AND
ABUSED.
MY BEEF IS WITH THE DEMOCRATIC
PARTY WHO LAID IN WAIT, BETRAYED
HER TRUST, DIDN'T TELL HER WE
WOULD GO TO CALIFORNIA.
MY BEEF IS WITH THE FACT THAT
THEY'VE DONE EVERYTHING THEY CAN
DO TO DESTROY HIS LIFE.
IF YOU DON'T BELIEVE HE'S A
GANG-RAPISTS, A PREDATOR,
STUMBLING DRUNK, HOW ABOUT HE
DOESN'T HAVE THE TEMPERAMENT?
THIS IS THE ONE THAT BOTHERS ME
THE MOST.
HE APOLOGIZED FOR AMY KLOBUCHAR
FOR SNAPPING AT HER.
WHAT WOULD YOU DO IF YOU WERE
ACCUSED OF ALL THESE THINGS, HAD
HER LIFE RUINED?
HERE'S WHAT I CAN, AMY KLOBUCHAR
SHOULD APOLOGIZE TO JUDGE
KAVANAUGH AND HIS FAMILY FOR
BEING PART OF A SMEAR CAMPAIGN I
HAVEN'T SEEN IN OVER 20 YEARS IN
POLITICS.
>> Sean: WHAT ABOUT THESE RED
STATE DEMOCRATS?
>> I THINK THEY ARE TOAST.
>> Sean: ALL OF THEM?
>> ALL OF THEM.
>> Sean: THE ONLY TWO THAT ARE
OPEN SEEMINGLY --
>> THEY ARE TOAST IF THEY VOTE
NO.
THEY SHOULD BE.
PRESIDENT TRUMP WON THE STATES
PROMISING TO NOMINATE
CONSERVATIVE JUDGES.
THIS IS A BUSH GUY.
HE WORKED FOR THE BUSH
WHITE HOUSE.
HE'S AS MAINSTREAM AS YOU CAN
GET.
HE'S BEEN ON THE D.C. CIRCUIT
COURT OF APPEALS FOR 12 YEARS.
GLOWING ASSESSMENTS OF HIS
CREDIBILITY, HIS INTEGRITY
BEFORE THIS HEARING.
IF YOU'RE GOING TO REWARD PEOPLE
FOR DESTROYING HIS LIFE BY
QUESTIONING HIS TEMPERAMENT THEN
YOU ARE SETTING IN MOTION THE
DESTRUCTION OF THE JUDICIARY.
AT TWO AND A REPUBLICAN WHO
WANTS TO QUESTION KAVANAUGH'S
TEMPERAMENT, WHAT YOU'RE DOING
IS THE PEOPLE WERE PUTTING --
>> Sean: FIVE WEEKS FROM
TONIGHT THE RESULTS WILL START
FLOWING IN.
IF YOU WENT PRETTY VIABLE, YOUR
COMMENTS ON THIS PROGRAM LAST
NIGHT AND YOU SAID THAT IF YOU
FALL ONE VOTE SHORT, THAT THIS
ELECTION FIVE WEEKS FROM TONIGHT
THAT THIS COULD BE A REFERENDUM,
THE PRESIDENT COULD RENOMINATE
KAVANAUGH WITH THE NEW SENATE
AND ENOUGH VOTES FOR TOMEI TO
CONFIRM HIM.
>> LOOKS LIKE THE PEOPLE DECIDE.
CORKER MADE AN OBSERVATION THAT
WE'VE GOT THE VOTES AND HERE'S
WHAT I WOULD SAY TO BOB.
WE HAVE TO WAIT ON THE FBI
REPORT.
LISA MURKOWSKI AND SUSAN COLLINS
REALLY WANT TO THE FBI TO
VALIDATE THE COMMITTEE'S WORK.
THEY ARE JUST ABOUT DONE.
I'M CONFIDENT BOTH OF THEM, IF
THERE IS NO CHANGE, IF THE FBI
LEARNS NOTHING NEW ABOUT THE
ALLEGATION OR LEGITIMACY TO
RAMIREZ, THAT THEY WILL VOTE FOR
KAVANAUGH BECAUSE WE'VE DONE
EVERYTHING WITHIN REASON AND I
HOPE JEFF FLAKE WILL ALSO -- HE
VOTED YES IN COMMITTEE AND NOW
HE'S TALKING ABOUT TEMPERAMENT
AND YEARBOOK ENTRIES.
TO THOSE WHO QUESTIONED THE
YEARBOOK ENTRIES, JUST LISTEN TO
WHAT YOU ARE SAYING.
YOU'RE GOING TO DECIDE THIS
MAN'S FATE BASED ON THE YEARBOOK
ENTRY.
>> Sean: ICE-THROWING.
AT THE SENATOR FROM HAWAII.
>> THE TRIANGLE.
IF YOU HAVE A DOUBT WHAT IT
REALLY MEANS, GO BACK AND TALK
TO JUDGE KAVANAUGH HIMSELF.
DON'T HUMILIATE THIS MAN.
>> Sean: IF THE FBI -- THERE'S
ONE REPORT THAT THEY HAVEN'T
TALKED TO DR. FORD.
IS THERE A NEED TO TALK TO HER?
>> THE LAST THING DR. FORD NEEDS
IN MY VIEW IS TO GO THROUGH THE
RINGER AGAIN.
SHE CAME FORWARD TO THE
COMMITTEE, COULDN'T TELL US
ANYTHING IN PERSON.
I THINK SOMETHING REALLY DID
HAPPEN TO HER, I AM CONVINCED IT
WASN'T BRETT KAVANAUGH.
IF SHE WAS WRONG ABOUT HER BEST
FRIEND BEING AT THE PARTY, WHAT
ELSE WAS SHE WRONG ABOUT?
HER BEST FRIEND SAYS I'M NOT
HERE TO REFUTE HER CLAIM, I'M
JUST SAYING I'VE NEVER MET BRETT
KAVANAUGH.
HOW DO YOU KNOW YOU JUST HAD ONE
BEER AND YOU CAN'T REMEMBER
ANYTHING ELSE?
>> Sean: SENATOR, YOU'VE BEEN
A FORCE FOR FAIRNESS IN THIS.
THIS SHOULDN'T BE REPUBLICAN OR
DEMOCRAT.
>> IT SURE IS NOW.
IF YOU DON'T GET WHAT THEY ARE
DOING --
>> Sean: YOU VOTED FOR BOTH OF
OBAMA'S NOMINEES.